We've got several tiki torches.
We've got methanol for fuel,
and we've got a
whole host of chemicals
that we're gonna mix in,
and see if we can get a
nice display of colored tiki torches.
[Captions by Judy V. at Y Translator]
[Music]
A while ago, we had a video showing how
to make several different colors of flame.
I thought that worked out pretty well.
On that video, YouTube user
redvsbluefanful wanted to know
if we can use the same ideas
to make colored-burning tiki torches
rather than just burning the fuel
in the little candle receptacles.
Let's look at some of the
things we're gonna try burning.
We've got lithium inside
of our lithium batteries,
which as we've seen before can
make a really cool bright magenta flame.
The boric acid in this roach killer
has done a pretty good job
of making it very bright green.
We've had mixed results
using potassium chloride,
which is a salt substitute
trying to get a purple flame.
It kind of works,
although it's not great.
So, normal isopropyl alcohol
gives us a very bright yellow color.
And in fact, it's so bright
that can often wash out other colors
that we get from burning the methanol.
So, I might try using just
a little bit of this mixed in
with the methanol to get
a smaller yellow flame.
I've done a couple
of experiments recently
mixing calcium carbonate
with the methanol,
and I think that might
give us another option
as we try and go
for a purple flame.
The copper sulfate that makes up
this root killer chemical
does an okay job of
making a bluish green flame.
We had some mixed results.
And in fact,
we had some mixed colors,
we had sort of blueish green
with orange mixed into it.
We'll see if we get the same thing
when it's burning in a tiki torch,
and then of course,
the methanol by itself
does a pretty good job
of burning blue
although it's a fairly faint blue,
so if there's a lot of light,
you can't see it very well.
That's one of the reasons
we're doing this at night.
I've also got this
large bag of driveway salt,
which is made of calcium chloride,
and that's what we tried
to use to make an orange flame.
It did an okay job,
and sometimes I thought that
crushing it up into a powder worked better
and sometimes it seemed like
just leaving it as pellets worked better.
So, we'll try using the pellets,
and see if we can get an orange flame...
more orange than the yellow color
of other types of fuel.
Here's the basic idea.
We've got some tiki torches
and some methanol for fuel.
We've got several different
chemicals that we can use
to try and change
the color of the flame.
Will it work in the tiki torches
the same way it did
in the little candles?
The two that I'm most
confident will work out
are the red and green colors
given to us by the lithium
and the boric acid, respectively.
I'm so confident those are gonna work.
I'm just gonna fill
one of these pots each
with some of our methanol,
and then add our lithium
and our boric acid to that,
and see if it burns out through the torch.
I bought these tiki torches at Walmart,
where they were two dollars
and fifty cents each.
So, really not breaking
the bank if you wanna try this.
[Music]
That is like a perfect amount.
12 ounces.
I guess this is designed
to hold about 12 ounces.
[Music]
Well, that was unexpected.
Guess let that be a warning
that there is a reason
we often say don't try this at home.
Apparently, there is a chance of
spontaneous combustion with batteries,
so be careful.
[Music]
This one I suspect
will be less exciting.
The boric acid, while doing
a great job of turning the flame green
doesn't typically you know,
react quite so violently as the lithium.
[Music]
Now, for these tiki torches to really work,
the wick needs to take the methanol,
and lift it up through the wick to the top,
so it will light and so
actually be burning the fuel,
rather than just burning your
melting the wick self.
It's a little hard to tell
once it's done that,
but the easiest way is
if the wick feels kind of cold.
You might be able to tell that
it's wet too if it's properly wicking.
You can see that it
will bring some moisture up.
of course, methanol
evaporates so quickly,
but nothing stays wet for long.
[Music]
Boom!
Right there.
I would say we've got a
magenta flame and a green flame
going quite nicely.
The magenta one you can see does have
a little bit of blue down at the bottom,
and a little bit of orange up at the top,
but overall that's a pretty reddish flame.
As a color comparison,
here's a tiki torch with
some regular torch oil.
[Music]
You can see how much more red,
and obviously, how much
more green our flame is here.
Those are the two I most
suspected we're going to work,
and so I just put them directly into
the tiki torches and it does work.
Some of the chemicals are going
up the wick with the methanol fuel,
and we're getting some
great color out of them.
For the rest of the tests,
I think we're going to try
some smaller scale things
before moving on to the full-size burns.
We've got a red.
Let's see if we can get a nice yellow.
I know we can get a nice yellow
by just burning the regular Tiki oil,
but I want to try and get
a smaller yellow flame
so it's not drowning out
the others the same way.
I'm going to have mostly methanol
and a little bit of isopropyl alcohol,
See if we can get a nice yellow
color, but smaller yellow color.
[Music]
Hey, that's a yellow flame.
Oh, where did it go?
This is safe.
[Music]
That's a yellow flame on the top.
Let's see if we can get
ourselves a nice orange
by adding some of the
calcium chloride pellets.
[Music]
We've got quite a bit of our
calcium chloride inside this container.
Let's fill it up with our fuel,
and see if we can get
a nice color out of it.
[Music]
That's got some orange to it.
It's also almost got
a little bit of purple to it.
It's not too different from some
of the purple tests we've seen before.
Question is whether
it will keep that same color
when we've got it
coming up through a wick.
Screw on the lid,
and try and gently encourage some
of that liquid to go up through the wick.
See how this looks.
[Music]
Well it's got some color.
Not bad.
I think that's an okay orange.
It's not a super vibrant
traffic cone kind of orange,
but it's certainly more
orange than pure methanol.
We got some of this salt substitute,
which as I said before
is the potassium chloride
trying to get a purple,
and this is one that's always
giving us sort of shaky, iffy results.
Let's see what happens
if we try and burn it through a wick.
[Music]
Now with this we are hoping for purple.
To me this is looking
pretty yellowish-orangey.
Not too different
from the calcium chloride.
Don't know if I can call that purple.
We got sort of a middling response
using the potassium chloride.
Let's see what will we get
using the calcium carbonate.
[Music]
Gotta say that mostly just
looks blue like plain methanol.
So maybe this test isn't going to
work out so great after all.
We'll try it through a wick
and see if it's any different.
Here is our calcium carbonate
next to our potassium chloride,
and both of them have maybe little
hints of purple down at the bottom.
But for the most part they're
kind of just orangey yellow.
These colors were already sort of iffy,
getting it to show through with a wick,
makes it a little worse I'd say.
It's just not very purple.
One final color test.
Let's see if we can get anything worth
mentioning out of this copper sulfate.
[Music
]That is just the color
of methanol right there.
Little bits of green jump out
in these tiny little spurts.
There you go.
So, if it's constantly being agitated,
we can get some cool green in there.
Agitation and air.
[Music]
Some of it splashed.
Kind of a cool effect
and some kind of cool colors
but really not something that's
gonna work very well through a wick.
We've got five torches set up here,
and I'm not 100% convinced
that all of them are gonna work.
This is a bit of a final test
rather than a final exhibition.
But let's light them up and see
if we can get some good colors.
I'm hoping for red,
orange, yellow, green, blue.
The blue is pure methanol,
which through a wick
might not burn the same color.
[Music]
Our calcium chloride looks almost
identical to our pure methanol at this point,
which makes me think
that the calcium chloride
isn't really doing too much
to change the color.
Maybe it is changing color,
but only the same amount that the wick
is changing the color for the methanol.
Honestly that might be...
That might be a better blue than
the one that's supposed to be blue.
Maybe we should switch
our blue and our orange
for better blue and orange.
[Music]
The green works excellently.
The magenta is not too bad.
It's not the strongest color.
Not compared to the green at least,
but it's pretty good.
The yellow works pretty well by
adding quite a bit of isopropyl alcohol,
and you can probably
burn pure isopropyl alcohol,
and get a similar result.
Although in my experience, that
does make a little bit bigger of a flame.
Not necessarily a bad thing.
But if you're going for a
bigger flame in this color,
then you can just use
the normal tiki torch fuel.
Getting the orange, and the blue,
and the purple didn't work out so well,
so I would say, you probably want
to stick to the green or the magenta.
One other thing,
they did have this much larger
tiki torch available as well.
I've got some green tinted fuel in this one.
We're gonna see how much
bigger we can really get this going.
[Music]
The idea with this one I believe
is that it's supposed to
have the fuel vent up to the top,
and you can get a much larger flame
because it'll come out
all the way around the wick.
[Music]
redvsbluefanful,
thank you for your suggestion.
Check your YouTube inbox.
We're sending you 25 bucks.
Remember guys,
if you've got a cool idea,
and you let us know,
and we make a video from your idea,
we will send you $25.
Nope.
Guys, that's not all,
we've got more for you to see.
If you click that little box up the top,
it'll transfer you directly to our last video,
and you should go check that out.
The box at the bottom will show
you what YouTube thinks you need
to be watching next.
And this bomb here in the middle
will subscribe you to our channel,
so you never miss out on a video.
Don't forget to ring that bell and
we'll see you in the next one.
Talk to you then.